so Sabrina we'll start with you so this
is an origin story so could you talk a
little bit about what happened in the
editing room to shape Benedict's
performance and his journey from surgeon
throughout the film well the the script
was basically set to go with that but as
far as putting it together you never
quite know how far you can stray from
your main character so there were scenes
in there that deviated from Benedict but
in this particular story we felt that
you had to stick with Benedict except
for the opening tease which gave you a
little flavor of the wacky world that we
end up in later in the movie so other
than that we felt pretty pretty Sookie
pretty secure pretty safe that we had to
stick with him because he did go on this
pretty intense journey the bigger
challenge for us was how big of a jerk
we could let him be or not be and we
tried all different levels and tested
that because we weren't sure what people
were going to accept and if we lost the
audience early because he was such a
jerk that nobody liked him they wouldn't
stick with them so we had to find the
right balance that was probably the
biggest hurdle we had to overcome as
figuring out how likable to make him but
still make him arrogant and confident
and all that kind of thing so he could
fall from grace and get to that low
point that he gets to so so that was the
biggest challenge other than that it's
pretty traditional editing and in the
mode of finding your story and
tightening and honing and all that kind
of stuff but another big challenge for
you was this was a lot of visual effects
is very challenging production could you
talk about the technical aspects that
were challenging yeah I mean these kinds
of movies are crazy intense and we have
a lot of tools that most other movies
don't have we we start with previz which
happens long before even the editors
come on board and and
there's stunt fees or fight phys and
then there's tech fizz and then you have
post vis so there's a lot of tools at
our disposal which becomes a lot to
manage in conjunction with working with
with Steph and his team I mean it was an
amazingly large crew I would say there
was something like 60 oh yeah and do yes
CPCC people I didn't even know all the
artists names there were so many people
but if there were amazing tools to help
us figure out the looks of things and
kind of discover and explore things too
that we would just weren't sure what
things were going to look like or be and
that that dictate a lot of what made
certain scenes more or less interesting
too how did you communicate the two of
you when daily yeah yeah every day I
mean we we had also Wyatt's Missy yeah
other editor that really work it came
actually on board before we start yeah
he showed up a month early days yet
London where the song was shot and we
were a little previously was actually
editing the previous we just kind of
unusual even for that kind of film that
we have the editor so early editing the
previous because on this film making
sure that what we previous was really
what we would fall in terms of shooting
was important because everything was
really complex to shoot so I think Wyatt
kind of working with Scott and all the
production crew and us visual effects
all together before we started to shoot
was key to the project actually yeah I
was crucial it was the roadmap for
shooting yeah because it was so
complicated as you saw on some of these
sequences that just had to be shot in
layers and just the the minutiae
figuring out how to shoot some of this
was really a huge town so we couldn't
have done it without that that to love
previous yeah um and then you were
saying just to go to the visual effects
the scope of this I mean there were so
many different types of visual effects
you had you said 1,450 shots you which
is everything not to you Jennifer but
they were they were pretty chunky chain
they were challenging so talk about the
just managing the scope and the
different types of ass I mean when when
we started on the fem swear i started in
number 2014 which was like two years ago
actually and Scott was clear that he
didn't want to have the usual magic that
we've seen in films before so it was
kind of a challenge to try and find new
ways of telling stories with magic and
which were kind of not seen before
because we've seen a lot of magic in
films so you know we looked at all these
optical illusion things you know that
we've seen the film obviously we had
lots of sources that we looked at also
fractals and and then we also wanted to
go into the world that Steve Ditko
created in the 60s and 70s the
psychedelic worlds that that is created
soul is colorful things so there's
there's a huge spectrum of magic
throughout the film's you know you've
got the mundane magic of opening pro
tools and things like that which is a
little bit more common and then we go
into falling cities and then you know
creating new dimensions and going into
crazy travels through a mind and
everything so it was really challenging
in terms of the amount of creative R&D
that we are we had to do for the film
Vince your company did that fantastic
scene in the beginning where London's
folding and all kinds of directions tell
us how you don't take it I'm still not
quite sure how we did that actually we
when we first got the previz I we
brought the whole crew into the theater
and we looked at it and it was silent in
the theater which is very unusual for
our crew you know everybody usually has
an opinion or a thought on how to
execute it and frankly we just we had no
idea the previous you know is just
consuming it's an it's a there's so much
that's happening visually that the
technical is one hurdle the like stuff
was alluding to one of the main
challenges is the creative side of this
because we inherently you have with
something so complex is something that
could fall into noise for an audience to
look at you know and so with so much
visual information so much movement and
all these things it really actually
landed more towards the creative side
the artistic side try
to balance these things out trying to
figure out really how do we direct the
eye where we need the eye to go with all
these moving pieces and parts stuff you
had a good idea initially which was lets
you know basically bear it down to the
just get the bare essentials in there
and let's figure out how we make the
motion and choreograph the scenes along
the sequence and have the as the
buildings are fractal lling and
Mandelbrot eng which is a whole other
technology that was you know crazy
trying to art direct a fractal is very
very very difficult okay they suffer a
lot ya know and suffer was amazing it's
amazing but it's taking v's and then
working it in layers which is kind of
the key to to anything that you're
building that looks visually complex
breaking down two layers and then
building the tech to be able to execute
on a grand scale so a lot of a lot of
development went into it but I'd say
actually a lot on the art artists side
incredible about that's one thing I
would say about I mean we can do a lot
of things today you know there's lots of
possibilities in the tools that we have
but i think it's finding the right
balance between the story where needs to
be told what visually is pleasing to the
audience and tells the story it's that's
the creative sign that is the most
challenging especially on this film and
also we had very little time to finish
it i mean we had five and a half months
in post to actually do all these things
so plus some reshoots happening in the
middle so it was a bit a bit of a
challenge Michael yeah so so the story
we heard is that you kind of came in
with the music and everybody feel ya
know tell us about that first I want to
apologize from dressed I clearly didn't
get the memo this this guy's look so
great and I'm like I feel like I just
wandered out of the alley which it kind
of did but anyway uh ya know when I
first knew about this film and in the
story I love that character as a kid I
mean my first introduction was when I
was at a flea market with my mom and I
found this random
a comic with it with dr. strange in and
I thought oh that is so cool so as a kid
I had this great sort of connection to
this character who I loved and the
defenders and all that so when I heard
that you were making this movie I
thought I want to do that movie because
that movie feels like an original story
you know nobody knows who this character
is for the most part and it was just be
fun to bite my teeth into a into an
original film like this and I went to
the meeting and they were going to show
me a lot of the film and I went to the
meeting but prior that week before I had
this idea and I was working out this
idea as a melody for Doctor Strange a
theme for Doctor Strange and I thought
you know what I almost called Kevin
foggy at Marvel and thought I'm gonna
bring something that I said you know I
better not even tell them because what
if the music doesn't fit what they're
doing so I decided to wait so I went to
the meeting I saw this footage all these
amazing scenes all this work that you
guys were probably in the middle of them
breaking down and having you know you
know crying fits over and I thought oh
my god this music could work really good
with this and so at the end of the
meeting I said you know I actually
brought something a piece of music i'm
thinking that i wrote could be the theme
for this and they were like wait what I
brought he pulls out a thumb drive yeah
honey can we play this somewhere they're
like yes and they all like ran into the
editing room and we plugged it in and
played it and that that became our main
theme for the for the film actually and
then then it was just often the races
from there but I knew I just knew I
looked at I knew I was going to have a
lot of fun with this film in this
character and I I loved him because he
was broken I love them because he had
this this this this inner pain and at
the same time he was also learning how
to help other people here was a guy who
who was in need of the most help and he
had to learn how to help other people
before even you know and so there was
this dichotomy within I'm a site which I
would really loved and I knew I could
make I always imagined tractive did
something sad in films there's something
about it that I i I'd love to go for
that sort of that that sort of feeling
in this film had it in spades I I
thought so and you all did incredible
work
could you elaborate a little bit about
how you brought that that story in that
character to the music well the theme is
a fairly you know I don't say
complicated thing but it's it's it's got
a full-on melody which plays out and and
through the film the idea was to play
the theme but without the melody at
first and slowly let the melody sort of
take over let the melody you know first
play it using chords first play using
orchestration and which hints at the
melody but doesn't really give you the
melody because I didn't want that to
happen until the moment where he rises
up from that staircase with the cloak of
levitation that flies down and grabs him
I thought that's where we should first
hear it and it's full-on you know big
moment and I and so the trick was well
how do we build the the ladder to that
to that moment so it was about you know
once he was trying to get his operation
once he was trying to fix his hands that
theme is playing through that entire
scene but it's not really the melody is
missing and you're just getting like
hints of the melody and and and and it's
a theme that i knew i could play very
simply and very poignant lee or it could
become something that was very heroic
and it was just sort of a fun puzzle to
solve on this and and and that was great
to work with a group of people were like
yes give us a melody give us something
that we can we can hum give us something
that we can you know use in a heroic way
like this and I'm a I'm a big fan of the
films of the you know 70s and 80s I grew
up in the 60s and they all had these
melodies and themes and my friends and I
would run around the yard singing these
things as we were playing and and I I
tend to just want to live that life
again so I I'm doing whatever I can so I
can continue to do that in my head with
these films that I get to work on today
please join me in thanking or speak